foreign
welcome to a design review for open
language for version 13.2
and um I guess we this is this our first
meeting about sound Envision stuff for
this version yes
okay
okay
to auto rotate based on camera top
orientation
so how do I see this
this is not an auto type yet hopefully
nothing will be visible by the user
videos will just be oriented the correct
way that's the goal okay fine
and and this was a user complaint for
the previous versions
so hopefully some users will be excited
to see that
is the programmatic control if you want
the thing to be you know to be oriented
differently
we didn't add an option to the video
object or import
I think we can add it to that is the
possibility to do so
um yeah for probably the next version
but the framework that we are putting in
place will be able to accept the input
from the user okay
as a GUI or what
as an option most likely okay fine
but so we just haven't defined that
option yet
correct and and we are not confident
enough into covering all of The Chronic
cases there are some cases of uh
non-multiple of 90 degrees rotations
it's unclear how if they are actually
useful uh so there is more that we need
to investigate before uh ethernet
comments you'd like to be able to click
on the video object and resize it with
his Mouse
yes we would like that too
um it is on the roadmap by unfortunately
a realizing the front-end feature that
isn't there yet
all right at the moment the the best bet
might be just using the image size
option
okay what's new in overlay video
um what's new here
you can text text and expression those
tentative tables as far as overlay we
supported another video or an image as
an overlay now we're supporting text or
style text or any arbitrary expression
arbitrary Graphics as well yes
Graphics was already supported now the
last item of that tentative table is a
function so we also accept a Time
varying expression based so the function
of time so if you want an animation
uh you mean an animated image well I
don't yeah maybe but I mean yes that but
but what about but so
this thing here is a function with T is
a time in seconds or what
yes a few seconds
it seems
okay I mean but arbitrary function you
mean a function function is that correct
it can be an arbitrary expression that
if we apply if we do F of D we'll return
something sensible the result of it is
checked
I I don't understand an arbitrary
expression with a variable T so you can
be here no sorry
yes yeah it can be a down value defined
function a function function a Time
series but it's a thing so you need to
make that look a little bit clearer but
it's something which is applied to when
you need to say what it's applied to
apply the time in seconds
correct
okay
what's new here this is the same thing
parameters
at a time varying function
okay
video time range what does that mean
now grid video overlay video and the
family of video frame map video map
can accept multiple videos the one thing
we had to hardcore in the previous
versions was if videos have different
duration how do we handle them do we
take the shortest where we where we have
content from all of them do we get
longest and
um we just do some kind of a padding the
choice until now was that we take the
shortest which is the intersection of
available content
now with this video time range option
we're proposing that we can say we want
intersection Union or even provide a
time interval oh come on guys surely you
can do better on the design than this
Okay so
you've got it's like multiple time
series right
yes how do we do this for Time series
um
so the time series have baked in some
interpolation right I mean the time
Series has time in it
um
uh
hey actually we have a suggestion here
from Sandra on our live stream it's an
interesting suggestion it says uh it
says he was just trying to do something
with a video putting a Time code on the
video
um but also wants to be able to have
something which puts the frame number
into the video
that's a good suggestion
that instead of
this function
taking
you know just the time variable why not
have it take hash time hash frame
Etc why don't have it take the usual
collection of Association variables
well we're back now to Overlay video
right the messiness there is that we
typically want a slot without a name to
work that's very convenient to just say
um
well yes and no I mean unless
but don't we normally in in video time
series map
video map time suit what is it called
video video map video map time series
yeah okay fine in that case we have uh
hash time hash frame Etc don't we truth
does it have a frame number as well in
actually frame number we don't have that
that might be interesting that would be
a useful thing to add yes look at it
okay
but the question here is whether we want
to be able to have something where the
overlay isn't just based independently
on time
but
can depend on something else and do we
want to provide those variables
so frame index and time are
interdependent obviously
um
so if it is just dot uh
I I'm not sure it is worth the
complication I'm not sure what other
things you had in mind that it could
depend on but I don't know I mean but
everything video
time series map
has many has like four or five things
that can depend yes yes it can deal with
uh it can get frames you can get chunk
get chunks of uh the audio track it can
get the time and I think the time
interval which gives you the boundary
the time boundaries of that frame
um
essentially all of the video map
functions go more into detail about more
for the advanced user where all of these
facilities are available all of these
overlay video video frame map are
essentially
shortcuts to try to streamline some use
cases all of this is achievable just by
using video map
all right fair enough
I mean I can see the argument for
putting a frame number here but I
understand also why
you can't have both things yeah I I'm
not I'm not against either just I think
only one argument or dysfunction that is
not an association would be convenient I
think
are you sure that you couldn't just have
it be an association and you'd have hash
time or hash frame number we could that
would force users to essentially just oh
with Point users to use pure functions
which is not necessarily a bad thing but
but kind of make the down value cases
slightly more annoying
um well
the down value cases just have to say f
of hash time Ampersand right
yes yeah every single time
yeah but every single time it's like a
you know look people who are annotating
videos
are often going to be annotating them
for very detailed scientific type
reasons
for which frame number is relevant
am I making sense
yeah we could switch this F of time to F
of three minutes no no don't do that
that's a mistake
I'm not sure I agree fully with this
statement you said something as as
Carlos said something like overlay video
I think I think people in different
fields May compute things for scientific
reasons fund reasons different things
but at the point that they want to
Overlay a video over another video or
some or something that's different this
is the case of the function where it's
explicitly pulling out a time variable
right that's the only case we're talking
about here we're not talking about any
other case
all right so the question is is it being
fed an association where it's hash time
hash frame number was it being fed just
a pure time
what's our analogy with video generated
functions and so on
this video generator only takes time as
input then that's what we should do here
we can't make that inconsistent
we can make sure to exemplify this to
show the user how to get the Flaming
that's fine all right let's talk about
video time range okay so now
you've got multiple videos
and you're putting them together
and the question is
how do they it's like multiple times
series and you're you're you know some
in some cases there's only one live time
series at that moment in some cases
there are two or three what do you do
am I am I right
that's correct the the difference that
time Series has is that it has baked in
a missing data method under a sampling
um yeah whereas it's not obvious what
you do with a video if you just don't
have a video in that in that region
correct right does time series have an
obvious padding option padding mechanism
because resampling yes we can no I don't
think so I think if you ask for a value
Beyond beginning and end time you just
get a message that says we can't we
can't get you that value let me let me
test that I'll let you know okay but
hold on what does this do so you've got
what's a typical case here
this is the case for
you know grid video for example and
you know there was a video of a of a
swimming turtle and a flying frog or
something and the swimming Turtle video
was shorter than the flying frog video
correct so at the moment we'll take the
shortest and that's obviously not
obviously wrong I mean what is the the
alternative is to not have this and just
said that's outside the scope of those
functions and do whatever processing on
the forehand you don't understand what
okay look I mean
that's a conform video thing I mean that
that will be working some kind of
control no I'm just saying that
um
in an alternative way is that
yeah you can form them first and you
define how you pad them to conform them
right you um you can achieve anything
that way okay yes indeed right so the
question is what is this and is it more
or less confusing than pre-padding
so just to a note the advantage of this
is you don't have to create additional
Assets in the middle of the operation to
just describe describe them after I
understand that but okay let's say the
total video ended and you just want it
to be you know Green in place of the
total video in that place in the grid
What do you do so by default we are
already planning we're already planning
to switch the default value of this
option to Union so this will take uh the
longest and we'll pad all of the other
two I understand how do you Pat it black
frames silence audio Yeah
Yeah uses video track padding and audio
track padding to say how things are
patterned which is not the same as what
you've said here about with a generic
planning option that that one is slight
outdated with the with Rogers Rogers
notebook sorry Roger and I didn't meet
okay all right fine
so
and originally we were thinking we'll
use padding just that the use of padding
became a little too messy so just
yesterday Carlo and I thought maybe it
is here to split audio and video let me
make a suggestion I don't understand
why you're not just using video trim or
whatever it's called
why you're not just taking Union by
default and then any of these other
things
you just trim the video to whatever you
want it to be I'm not against that uh uh
that that was the initial implementation
we thought offering a bit more
flexibility to the user if they had
specific users but I know some because
isn't it just wrapping one function
what's the function called that no it's
not really up here this is doing things
a bit more efficiently than this
two-step process of trimming and then uh
doing the operation this is baking
essentially just seeking in the past
that needs to be seeked
and when one video finishes looks at the
padding values and puts users where does
this go is this in the outer function
and if so how does it reference
okay but but the first two seconds of
all videos of all inputs I don't
understand that because you might want
sort of you know the frog has not yet
started jumping so you want that one to
be black and then you want to align okay
let me understand something don't we
have absolute times possible in videos
how do how do we do it's like sound
notes and things how do we do the
concept of
you've got you know in your grid okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna take jumping frogs
as an example in your grid I want the
grid square that corresponds to the Frog
when it is jumping to light up and at
other times I want it to be black
So within that video there was a moment
the frog jumped at 3 17 PM another fraud
jumped at 3 18 and 20 seconds and so on
right I want to line those up so I'm
seeing the sort of the the full you know
jumping in real time so to speak with
the little boxes in the in the grid
video coming up when there was a jump
there so
yeah that that I think is a slightly
different use case that what we had in
mind for this the the idea of real time
range is not to change the alignment
between tracks if that makes sense so
you you you're not they're all anchored
at one at the beginning but but isn't it
the case that video has the possibility
of having some kind of absolute time
marker no those uh you you can get
submit data of when the file was saved
sometimes when the video was shot oh
wait wait I thought audio had the
possibility of having having an
alignment that was based on an absolute
time or am I wrong no no not that I am
aware of at least well okay but time
series does have that
all right sometimes there is absolutely
has that yes seems useful for audio and
video as well
so that is not because when you have
never seen that have you seen that in
any format or standard no I have not
seen that in any metadata I wouldn't
surprise me if it eventually arrives but
we have not seen that no but it seems
like something for you know if one's
using these things for scientific
purposes it seems useful to me
if one really is going to compare videos
and things rather than
I think that you know for for many of
those things like let's say images you
know image workflows in medicine I think
that they record when
things were yeah uh recorded yeah and
there's a bunch of other you know it's
400 other properties for you know
um
or something yeah
okay
um but but I haven't not seen that in
video but okay finally but it's okay
whatever metadata you want but I haven't
seen a codified player I bet there are
dates I think that you know metadata can
be anything I'm sure it can be recording
date
or some such but the timestamps are
always relative
okay but to me it seems like this is a
somewhat impoverished piece of
functionality anyway relative to what it
could be I would have thought it would
be better to just take Union by default
and
you know specify in each individual
video
well are you the video track padding
does that go in each individual video or
is that going over he's going to
functions that eat videos
but so every video has to have the same
track padding
is that correct with this design we have
there yes yeah
Rebecca who is developing this is has
been working on accepting different
video paddings for each input but it's
not ready yet
okay but how would you do that from a
design point of view
I would do it similarly to the time
series right which is what time series
put it into the video yeah exactly time
Series has oh okay The Missing Method
right The Missing Method handling in
each time series
and why does it say video track padding
wise into just video padding
oh we weren't sure on the name
um those were our two candidates
but so in general
an audio padding would either be silence
or music or something
yeah at the moment I think we only
support uh a real value so it's constant
padding
what is it in audio what does that mean
yeah silence con yeah constantly silence
different types of Silence
How can there be different types of
Silence well your speaker Position will
be different you will not hear anything
anyways
whatever that's in the category of of um
yeah right silence who cares right yeah
okay but so there's only one setting for
audio track padding then
what happens when I said effectively yes
but why do we have a why do we have an
option there's only one setting yeah so
so this is so you're right that it is
silence but if you're looking at
analysis operations like working at the
max value or whatever that could affect
it
I think it's a very Corner case as well
that's fair we we could do other audio
paddings like reflected or periodic but
I really don't think any of them will be
useful the only one is silence
yeah so so let's just review this again
so the question I think that there are
other things that we're missing for
audio which is you know um tapering down
tapering up
sure that that audio fade we have you're
right yeah fading it down fading up you
know
or unfading
look
what you're basically saying is
first of all I'm not buying the video
time range thing I think these things
should just be Union
and I don't really know what this video
padding thing is going to be other than
I suppose you could imagine some frame
coming up saying we're not ready yet or
whatever other than just black
I think fixed is another good default if
you click on that video track padding we
have it documented yeah
there's boundary frames for padding what
does that mean it means Frozen frame
freeze it
yep
yeah okay
yeah those are somewhat useful okay so
let's just understand what this is again
I mean other other functions like is
there a video trim or video take what
happens if you do a video take over a
larger range
than the actual video occupies I think
at the moment that just Returns the
original video but I'd have to verify to
make sure that is done because I mean
there could be a padding for that as
well
and it could be you know you have the
Jumping Frog and then the frog is Frozen
for the next five minutes
yeah at the moment it just returns
um the original video so essentially
intersection I guess
I think it would be a really bad side
effect Stephen
well okay but so what you're suggesting
is a video padding option which is an
option either to the over function like
Grid or something like this
that sort of reaches down and pads the
videos when they don't fill the you know
full time or video padding as a function
as an option to a video itself where it
looks to see what the over function is
asking for and pads with whatever it's
you know coming up being told to pad
with is that correct
I think so the the original proposal was
both video track padding and video time
range to be options for the over
function however I could see uh moving
the video attack padding to the video
object itself well as an alternative
right in other words you look for video
padding video padding are automatic
in the over function
will then look to the under functions
if
right I I mean I don't know whether
that's possible yeah and would it be
okay to roll out the two in two separate
phases or did you yeah that's fine yeah
okay but video and I think it should
probably be called video padding I don't
really see the point of the track word
okay
and if you think audio padding is never
gonna be added I'm wondering why not go
back to padding well again depending
unfortunately with good video we have
some special
frame by frame padding right padding
size and I'm I'm worried because of
different fittings I would leave it as a
video padding option yeah
um
and there's no function video pad or
anything like that what are the what are
the functions that allow you to is there
a video trim I can't remember is
videotape it's a video trim yes
okay but is there a video anti-trim is
there a video there's no video on
YouTube
okay
I think we could have a video pad or we
could change videos
pad or confirmed videos
um I developed it to
I think video dream as Roger said having
the side effect of generating giant
video for a mistaken second argument is
a bit dangerous but yeah it seems no I
mean there was videotaped that he said
but yeah yeah I mean we don't have
videotape we have videotape which all
right let's keep going
okay next up here we have generated
asset location
Cloud object public
yeah well okay so what that's for is
make it so that I can send this notebook
to somebody and not have it
have unfound videos right correct
um
that's fine now I hope that we're going
to have that easily accessible from the
GUI underneath the video right
um we've made our update for the audio
uh for the video uh it might be in the
next release
let's try to push hard to get it in this
release it was really a bad idea to not
have that we can we can add it easily
from the dot dot dot menu I think that
should be
get it okay
I mean do I need to look at this to
understand what you're talking about
there so this is just the value of the
option right you could for example
I understand it I'm asking I'm asking I
just want to be able to see
if I take video and I just take an
example video here
then
um
okay now where does it say video is not
in the it doesn't uh you you I think
that the way where we could have this
easily accessible isn't that many I
think no but we need some indication
that the video is not in the notebook
here
otherwise this is just going to be a
disaster every single time it's already
bitten me many times it's kind of like
it's just dumb I mean you know so we'll
have to go I guess yeah go ahead the
cloud object public thing you could set
your dollar generated asset location I
don't care what I'm setting I don't care
about setting anything I'm telling you
this look
yeah and I am aware of what you're
talking about
um
I mean that one is stored in the
notebook but then present what
wait a minute I usually use one million
together data not a notebook store now
yeah yeah yep now audio object has it in
Prototype
if you do audio of example data car.mp3
or yeah
hello hello hello I'm going to record
lots of audio here see what happens
really that's in the notebook now is it
that is not in Notebook but then why
doesn't it say it
that arrow on the right
so yeah
ah [ __ ] come on you got to do better
this is our pattern use it
data not in notebooks store now
okay just just okay
I really don't like this I really don't
like it this is just gonna burn people
every single time
that's silly
you can have you can have more stuff
look okay
can you please try to come up with a
version of this that follows the pattern
that we have here if you can't do that
I'll try and word it for you so okay the
more thing we can change I just want to
make sure you do you want the text
visible by default or tooltip is fine I
think you should say Here Local file I
don't think the name is is makes a damn
bit of difference to anybody but what's
important is that's a local file
I won't disagree yup in the case of in
in Notebook and memory we can say either
nothing or a notebook
yeah that's fine okay but I mean I think
this needs a Design This needs a design
which makes it clear
this is not in The Notebook
okay so sending some of the notebook is
not going to work
okay
now I don't know I mean something as
small as this I don't know how big this
is
does it say how big it is
no why doesn't say how big it is it's
five seconds but it doesn't no no but
why doesn't it say right in the duration
size blah blah blah kilobytes or
whatever
right it will can be misleading because
if it is an MP3 and then you're bought
in a notebook the size can balloon up
several months
we realize soon as
um notebooks have these assets
can can handle assets we have we have
talked to John in front and about that a
lot and okay so wait a minute are you
telling me that right now if I say store
a notebook it's just going to blow the
blow the thing up because that's not
going to work
what you should do is store it as a byte
can you click well you just do it does
it by today right okay
no no no no but I'm saying the following
don't expand it up you know if it's a
DOT MP3 or something just store the MP3
as a byte array
an actual file to access the data in
plate and process it and all of these
things wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute
this is the case where you are going to
store it in the notebook if during that
kernel session you want to create a
temporary file export it to a temporary
file and manipulate it there so be it
but the important thing is that transfer
wise it's in the notebook and it didn't
get blown up into some huge mega
symbolic structure and that's the the
plan with the front end is going to
provide this temporary file system I
understand but I'm saying even though we
don't have that now do it yourself
I I don't think it'll fit into 13-2
anyways at this point image has the same
uh has suffered from the same thing for
a long time I would I would just happily
make sure
images it is in the notebook but it it
blows up when it comes to a notebook and
that that has been a problem for a while
that we're trying so I'm planning to
address no listen I haven't seen that on
the front-end road map in those meetings
I have not heard about this so I'm
skeptical with other things happening I
uh well I was out last week but Carlo
has seen prototype just last week it's
not it's not finished and I'm not
qualified to speak on the status of the
project but my impression is that things
are actually happening all right okay
fine well all right fair enough that I
want to make on the audio object is that
we've had this in Notebook in memory
mode forever uh if you say normal of any
audio object yeah
transfer gets Imports of data in that
GUI itself and it will be shareable
however you want well that's obscure yes
yes this is why we've we're trying to
add something right so so it's not
really that practical
uh you know that's a blown up version
again I know which is not gonna work
well so you're basically telling me we
can't do anything useful until the blood
no no there's not two so I think that
especially for a smaller size all the
objects which I I don't think are that
uncommon the the Inca blown up version
is not terrible the other option that
you have when you click that button is
to stir up the stuff in a cloud object
it can be either private yeah okay well
so why don't you provide that you know
you just click on the button
Stephen wants it in the in the video GUI
I think right Stephen
that that's there I'm guessing you wanna
why does it do something different from
this because it relies on completely
different mechanisms and we've talked
I've talked to Lou and this Anita and
this the what they currently have is not
adaptable to the needs of them but but
okay so look this isn't good enough
because it doesn't make it clear
well yeah that it actually does
something to click this button
and this should say
and you know what would be nice if we if
I take what Stephen said earlier on
which I kind of like I mean the the
thing that the sort of first the stuff
on the left there we use something that
indicates whether it's local
uh you know I mean the three states
basically like in memory uh local
um URL Cloud I think yeah General URL or
Crap Cloud so let's say that it was
local file system
you click this thing
and now you can see the state change
which thing this thing here the left you
know on the left why would you click the
left no no you click on the right but
then the state on the left oh yeah no I
agree yes if you if you if you it
happens I still have a notebook that
already happens unfortunately we rely on
design I can't see it
um
there we go okay but it's unclear that
that's on the notebook so it just needs
so as you said we can make that clearer
just like it did here
store
you know data not in that notebook store
now greater than greater than sign
or something or you know data data in
local file
store
change storage no because it's really
either coming in or going to the cloud
no no no
the whole point is you're going to store
it
look I don't know look at look at the
wording that's been used elsewhere
please yeah but we've got exactly the
same as elsewhere
I know I don't know why this one doesn't
have that option but it doesn't have
that option I think so I don't think I
don't have the option so go find the
ones that do and follow them I already
did and in fact we are using some of the
code but we cannot I don't care about
the code I care about the words
yes okay so can we find the words and
use the words
um you can if you want you can is do uh
numeric array instead of data set that
will have I think uh all of the options
that you are looking for what do you
want to it's just like array of range
1000
that should if I remember yeah sorry one
million
I think that should bring up the menu
okay
so that so use exactly the same menu
so uh
I mean with the with the appropriate
other things about local Cloud blah blah
blah okay so I think what this should
say
is
okay normally it should say data not in
Notebook
store now don't say Chase anything just
say store now and make it clear that
with a guilla May or something that you
click it to get something to happen
mm-hmm okay okay
and I think as far as size we can give
the file size as well as the expected
storage in Notebook which will
eventually change again after you've had
a chance to iterate it sure
okay
okay let's take a look at some more of
these
remove background
that unfortunately is not working at 13
too
we could talk about design but
well I mean remove background is
something for individual images and
clearly for a video it's fancier
yep
maybe we'll come back to this event but
the thing is that the design we have in
remote background
um is is really not holding up even with
the newer methods for image background
removal and falls apart or what isn't
holding up about it it's it's just not
working with all the methods like the
neural network methods what would you
mean not working I mean you could say
remove background of an image and it
does what it does
yeah the default usage it has yes
specifying options and methods
um make the two things Clash you might
specify an option that uh makes the
argument not work essentially
unfortunately with the design as it
could I see I see okay all right fine
but so you're saying the methods you
know don't support the
controls that remove background
currently has yeah and some of the new
methods are not easily customizable with
the controls the background currently
has
okay
and I have to say remove background is
not as as powerful as the function has
suggested to be in the past couple of
versions so we're thinking of cutting
that anyways for image as well with
neural neural network methods or other
other more recent methods anyways so
let's come back to this once we have a
better proposal okay
okay
what is this video frame fold video fold
that that was very preliminary
we could bring up do you have a
prototype we have a type in Prototype
and there's a CVS page
um yeah
last time I heard this it wasn't very
cool yes but
but maybe we can cook it here
it's something that maybe could go for
32 but we're not convinced uh foreign
lovely magnificent but you know honestly
I think this is such a I I'm not seeing
a case
I this seems very bizarre to me
for an actual Full Speed video seems
really bizarre
but there are operations that really
need to fold something like
Transformations from one frame to
another and then really
compose them on top of each other or
things like motion magnification there
are so many operations that really need
to keep track of a state separately from
whatever is the output
sure
but let's let's enumerate them
okay let's do let's do a number of them
which case
we'll also know what options we need to
kind of
I mean it's magnificent it's lovely to
imagine kind of a functional Programming
type play I mean we don't have a video
Nest list
no the the concept of that is strange
because
it's more natural I agree it's natural
because it's a list of frames right yeah
Nest I'm not sure what that would mean
did you see Stephen
I mean but but I think we've served some
kind where it's using
I I just don't really see this
accumulation concept I mean the minimal
case of bold is like an accumulate and I
just don't see that as being a thing you
commonly want to do with video it's kind
of like what are you doing you're you're
kind of filling in I mean there's an
occasional video where you're like
filling in all the different I mean the
obvious usage is
um
um iir filters right where each next
step is computed as a function of the
current step and yes this output so that
kind of thing would be made so where do
you use an IR filter to a video
that is a good question though we should
uh let's let's research yeah let's
answer it first
image rotate great
Ethan is commenting about video effects
as an alternative to image effect
I think we've talked about that we're
just not quite there yet
and support for time varying parameters
is that obvious how that works or does
it work in some weird way
so the the easiest one image rotate that
we have first on that list instead of
rotating the whole video by 30 degrees
you can rotate gradually from zero okay
but how do you specify that in the image
you say image rotate of what
image Rotator video comma function which
takes time in seconds as arguments I
hate that I hate that whatever you've
done that a million times now I guess I
guess we have to deliver that
it's not my favorite piece of design
okay
let's look at them I'm curiosity's sake
what do you think would be a valid
alternative
assuming that we sorry
the conversation I understand
oh we should have bullet time
it was lovely
didn't you just see the Matrix
yeah
it means some kind of I'm I'm joking but
there are Notions of time there's sort
of event time for instance right you
know when this thing happened and do
something different no I understand I
understand but but I think Carla was
asking a different question which is a
pure design question of you know I don't
like the fact you say image rotate of
image comma 30 degrees or image comma
pure function
I don't like the idea
that that pure function then seeps into
the first argument
it doesn't we we only take time varying
parameter for videos
but I mean you know as opposed to an
image that is somehow going to start
singing and dancing at you
because for an image it's just there's a
single moment in time because it's just
the image but if you have a video what's
happening is somehow that second
argument is sort of seeping into
like that bothers me what's an analogy
to this
what's an analogy
um
it's kind of like I mean it's a map
thread it's kind of deal well I mean
it's literally a different use case it
see it's a different type and hence it
has a different
um configuration of you know follow-on
arguments
you can do video comma 30 degrees can't
you so we'll just rotate the whole video
by the degrees Yeah it's the special
case of a function
that
a non and I don't constant function I
don't really like it because I think it
somehow
you know yeah it's a non-constant
function except if that function
happened to be 30 degrees Ampersand it
would be equivalent to just saying 30
degrees without the function right right
boy so the map that has exactly this
mechanism of both of those cases in my
friendly
example of SMP
it was it was a disaster
I mean admittedly it was a much more
common case there
of many functions that had the
alternative of either a constant or a
function
okay
and I can't immediately give you a
situation in which
the well
right I mean
in this particular case
you want a quantity object
a you know an angular quantity object
there and so a function f or a string or
something
would be
not
I mean I could imagine a rotate
where you say you know top left or
something like that
I don't know I'm not thinking of a case
where there's an overlap between where
you want it to be a pure function when
you want it to be a literal object
in this case I'm not thinking of an
overlap
but I think right what's that which is
good right yeah right I know but I'm
saying I'm worried that there are in
fact overlaps
with some of these functions
so I I wasn't sure what your concern was
now I think I have a better idea
I mean I'm not seeing it with any of
these specifically
uh
you know unless there's one where for
example where the image recolor
could take a function as its second
argument to represent oh actually there
is there is some some
um
so for example image transformation that
takes oh that takes an argument it works
surprisingly
but it is surprising how can it work
it's taking a bringing function yes
in terms of function
yes but how do you know that the outer
function that's a total hacker they have
very different I know it's got two
arguments so you can you can that one
has two arguments but if I can imagine
another case yeah one of these things
eat say one argument function and then
your toast
I agree I have I I looked at all the
functions that we have under this
functionality and none of them seem to
have that kind of overlap
but I do agree that if there were
hanging by a thread
um
alternatively all of these we could do
with video frame map kind of a
setup as well if if you think this is
really hanging by a thread I think
alternatives
I I kind of disagree in the sense that
we we control the list of things that
this gets added to and we have made sure
that this kind of collision doesn't
happen
ah sign until we have a function where
it does happen and then we say oh people
have to remember this exception because
of this obscure thing
but we have a limited number of image
functions that accept videos and we're
not
all right well look I I don't like it
very much but you've already crossed
this bridge with some of the video
generators and audio generators we have
again this function versus single
argument thing
all right let's keep going here
change the color of the frame of image
yes okay does that happen now yes
it's a pretty blue
and so it is lovely
I think the usefulness is if you come
con compare Graphics of a disk to
rasterize Graphics of a disk
yeah that's a good point
[Music]
that's useful that's really useful I
will save a bunch of stupid confusion
good stuff
okay what's this oh that's just the okay
which compose
so that allows you to just compose
directly so if I take this
and I say
image compose
that comma Style
hello
comma yellow
it's nice yep
magnificent
okay
do we know people are using image Stitch
we've got some bugs and feedback
so yes
now this thing is that the projection
spaces we have talked about I think a
couple of times this might be a third
the third time
um the three projection spaces we're
suggesting we have now is plane which
project what are we talking about are we
talking about image set for image Stitch
yeah we're gonna have sparkle image
presumably yep
well I think image Stitch is not going
to be the main source of our spherical
images anyways there are 360 cameras
that would give us the bigger Source
right
although you could be taking pictures
with your ordinary camera sure and
stitching them together and making them
wanting to make them into a spherical
image exactly there's there's an
orthogonal
image Stitch that's something what it
was the other who you said
there's planes very much there there are
planes there are cylinders and there are
spheres so these are the three modes
that we imagine people have the most we
have spherical image but we don't have
cylinder image
do we or do we we don't the usefulness
of having the cylindrical stitching is
that you assume that space around you is
a cylinder and not a plane so the
projection avoids having huge warping on
the corners of that stitched image I
understand but if we're going to do a
cylindrical image don't we need a
cylindrical image object I don't think
so I think just this stitched image is
what people typically want to have like
the panoramas that are generated from
phones
okay
are you going to show me this picture or
yep okay you can
start from the one above
I should let me just ask about these
other things first
okay barcode image better back end great
great great great equal
so what is that doing that one was
discussed in uh LCC once
and what's the issue
um the things we basically changed the
heuristics for whether
white should be equal to grade level to
RGB color 111 yes
which it should be right
I don't think they are actually
well it should be shouldn't it
oh this one is yes and then whether now
also do RGB color one one one one
well here let me just show you okay
gray level one
okay another those two are literally
equivalent now yeah add another one that
as well should be true so the logic
there was not fully worked out
and now they are it is now okay great
all right let's go spherical here
so I assume that the sparkle image thing
is dovetailing with Jose's lovely astral
Graphics stuff
right
what we used here is not using any of
the Astro Graphics or geography no I
understand but but we need to do that
yep what is this and I don't think we
can make that
clean enough for 13 too but this is just
what is this what is this
it's very very slow
I think this is a usage of texture and
spherical plot
uh from the quick look that I had yep
what spherical plot I didn't think we'd
surface that yet
oh you designed that in version six even
what
what is spherical plot all right go look
it up read this thing documentation
oh spherical plot 3D yeah yeah that's a
function plotting yes yeah okay no I
understand that that's fine
that's a useful function right
but I think that's what we said is using
that as a prototyping vehicle which is
totally the wrong thing but yeah it's
totally the wrong thing
okay
so what do you what what's he going to
show here what would you say so what
what we are saying is that with image
Stitch returning or accepting that
projection space being sphere this is
where we're gonna go next we're gonna
have a spherical image we could possibly
have a spherical video
um it's called the spherical image
that has some kind of viewer yep
okay and where the where it is possible
to get the thing to just be a projection
because I mean we're trying to have you
know spherical position spherical
Etc generalizing the Geo stuff right but
you know you should be able to just take
spherical
um
spherical projection
and uh
I'm sorry uh you know a sphere image
spherical image it should probably be
called yeah it's a spherical image
and then you can display it with a
spherical projection
am I making sense so that you could
display it in a mole wide projection or
something like this
to put in your notebook and then there's
another thing where even when it's
displayed like that it could have some
interactive component where you can you
know press it and do something and or if
you've got your virtual reality you know
your VR set up you can view it in that
sure actually that's a good idea now we
can reuse all the projection the whole
projection subsystem yeah right the plan
from spherical look that's the idea for
spherical position and spherical and and
you know I guess it's
um
spherical Graphics like Geographics
that that's a Jose production
okay
we already talked about this right
correct
okay that's nice I'd like to see some
natural design of those
I mean there's 400 things in input
export so the summary thing
that's for import right that's very
import about 200 formats
okay and and the default is just going
to give us some very basic elements but
the framework upgrade is going to allow
developers to add any additional
elements they want to add to the summary
okay
chess game formats that's exotic
um you have to get that from CBS
uh where do I get it from here
oh halfway through
be nice if we could actually do
something with the notation once it
comes in
yep we have two very excited developers
on these two formats next up uh we're
gonna have our own engine and a
connection to stockfish which is the
most popular chess engine and we're
gonna allow you to play chess in our
system
okay but how do we represent
symbolically a chessboard
um that that string is the best
representation that's called the fence
string PGN which is the other format is
also so I understand that but if you
want to manipulate this symbolically
what do you do
we don't have that we could because
there was a guy at the summer school
this year who did a nice job of using
multi-way systems to represent chess
game endings and so on I think we should
you know if we're going to do this we
should have some
I mean you know I did this whole study
of games and puzzles and things and
there were some of these simple symbolic
representations of all sorts of things
there
okay
I'm just trying to think because we
don't want to end up with
ah boy how do we do this
well I think it's a separate discussion
separate meeting sure
um
because you know you can't play chess
because the rules of chess
like this guy at least for end games
encoded them as symbolic transformations
those rules won't do you any good if
what you've got is this weird string
thing
right
so
uh
all right
I think I really see this as the
simplest First Step which was completely
a hobby project a side project
of this
I yeah I completely agree let's design
it yeah but like many things that we
imported early on we didn't have any
objects in the system
um chemistry or
um Geo or you know early on right
um
this was the chap
okay
I don't know what his representation is
oh look chest position you know that's
useful thing but this is an example of
where
you know this is computation being done
with chess positions
so that's why I think it's useful to
look at
I don't need to actually
okay
all right anything else for this meeting
I got through it all well done
very good
okay Roger I'll see you elsewhere yep
see you in a little bit okay thank you
okay bye bye